hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dinner with an owl I'm
not even gonna bother trying to explain
this one because frankly you have dinner
with a welcome mr. Webb mr. Brown is
already waiting for you you will find
him in his office down the hallway thank
you very much
who the hell are you have a pleasant
stay sir what is this a hotel why are
you here who are you what's happening
here I don't know how do I move umbrella
stand
I don't need an umbrella at the moment
hey buddy
is there an owl living here should I be
worried mr. Brown awaits you in his
office
alright fine okay that's connealy do
okay
hello mr. boo are you a ghost
nice to meet you mr. Webb did you have a
nice arrival are you okay I'm fine thank
you mr. Webb you look hungry though
business can wait until tomorrow
well before we eat you have to meet the
other guests gasp okay mr. owl i i'd
like you to introduce you to to you miss
april merit April this is my business
partner mr. Christian Webb nice to meet
you it's a pleasure but don't you think
it's quite odd that he's in LA this is
her daughter Josie
hello sir and you already met my Butler
Declan over there very well will humph
guys what's going on here he's an owl
let's have dinner oh my god crazy here
there's goddamn owl hi
delicious isn't it
a true declan really surpassed himself
this time
yummy what do you think mr. Webb
I think you're an L I'm more interested
in why you are an owl I'm more
interested in why you so everyone finish
yes mom I will guide mr. Webb to his
room Ven
okay all right should I stay here with
mr. brown I'll be right back okay we'll
see each other tomorrow mr. Webb just
come to my office when you're ready
you've got a lot of work to do I am
still confused ah hello your room is
upstairs okay second door on the left
okay what's wrong with mr. Brown so now
that we are alone what thank is wrong
with mr. Brown why is he an owl he might
hear us why shouldn't I speak out what
he is yeah that's a little confusing why
would I because it's dangerous to
provoke him oh he doesn't seem to be
aggressive okay but he has been in the
past Lizzy how long have you been here I
don't know exactly what you mean you
don't know weeks maybe even months
that's a big difference he won't let us
leave oh great
no what do you think about Declan what's
Declan in all this I don't know if we
can trust him
alright maybe you can find out oh great
I get to solve this do you want to leave
this place of course I do you crazy
idiot smack let's go then he is with
Josie right now
and I won't leave without her great cool
let's just go a get her let's push that
out in the face beat him up what could
stop us who could stop us you
underestimate mr. Brown sometimes he
likes in the dark eavesdrops out
conversations I think even poison that's
the only way you could help us is to
neutralize him before you fall under his
spell
oh you all run by me again what the [ __ ]
is happening here because I'm I'm a
little bit lost also if I may have I
just been standing here since the
previous night to be like oh my God he's
actually your now all alright fine then
that's how it's gonna be
cuz there's nowhere else to go office it
is then hey hey mr. brown good morning
mr. Webb all right cool
yeah just hand over the contracts and we
can get straight to work all righty then
here you go do Skoosh you got it mr.
Brown later that day alrighty then
enough for today
we're making good progress here see you
later at dinner see there mister buddy
boo Oh God
I don't know why I was just standing in
front of your desk for hours and hours
and hours god I look depressed
little lady oh I went there that's it
that was it that was a decision that I
made okay hey how's it going Butler
Declan how may I be of service
let's see may I ask you a personal
question Declan
cut straight to the point here Declan
suddenly sir they like working for mr.
al Brown well he's a good man
I guess have you ever thought about
quitting your job excuse me do you think
about leaving this house it's not that
easy I will take care of it
but I need your help what should I do
can you provide some sort of weapon
maybe a none Briella type well there are
plenty of knives in the kitchen
that should do meet me tomorrow at this
place we have to know okay
righty-ho then ah good how was work
honey
mr. Webb is a tough negotiating partner
but I'm confident that we can conclude
an agreement we'll find a solution for
our problem soon ha ha and chop chop
knife knife yeah you're our only chance
Christian don't worry I got it it'll be
over soon huh boss tie album I'm afraid
it may already be too late
well apparently or wait until tomorrow
no matter what we do
okey-dokey then how about hi mr. Webb
what are you up to I I knew it all the
time but it won't work you hear me mr.
Brown Declan
oh I didn't do anything wrong sir it's
me who decides about that come to my
room after dinner no sir please okay all
righty then
here it is I'm I don't know where I am
there I am Thank You Declan I'll take
care of it
be prepared to leave this house soon a
boss should have stabbed him in two but
what do ours have buts see it see it
gots murder in the dude yeah you go
gonna stab an owl man
let's see all right knife to face my
knife your ha ha that seemed like
unnecessary murder but I it's dead it he
come on now oh well that well I did that
then so there we go
not sure why let's get out of here I
guess
can we really leave now mommy I think
it's already too late for him
[Music]
oh no not again
I'm so thirsty let's have dinner welcome
mr. Jordan mr. Webb is you'll find him
in his office down the hallway thank you
very much
Oh have a pleasant stay sir this place
looks strangely familiar like I remember
it from a weird long-forgotten past mr.
Webb nice to meet you mr. Jordan did you
have a nice arrival yes but you look
hungry but before we do you have to meet
the other guy I'd like you to introduce
you to miss April Merritt April this is
my business partner mr. Callum Jordan
nice to meet you it's a pleasure is this
a is this a loop until I figure out the
real answer here it is good night I'm
gonna go off now not stab nobody yeah
sleep well mr. Jordan oh you know I will
with my knife that I don't have cuz I'm
no stabbed day five here the contracts
mr. Webb oh boy let's hope we don't
negotiate too hard I need to get in an
argument with you
okay I'm gonna skip this possibly
copyrighted song did that happen
wait why did that happen see my flex in
there which is super weird of facing the
wrong way for that but okay hey buddy
boo how may I be of service
what's for dinner today buddy boo what's
for dinner
mashed meets two wishes can I stab those
in the my mouth what do you recommend a
drink we've got a decent selection of
red wine sir just don't drink the tap
water why shouldn't I
well it's been fused and the water in
this area's a bit limey may I ask you a
personal question do you like working
for bitter web he's good bad I guess you
very thoughtful quitting your job I
don't I don't want to do this here have
a contract all right well I guess I've
got to get a weapon man I didn't want to
do that how was work right about here it
is your knife sir ah excellent can you
give me one more knife can you give me
enough I'll have another another one
here you go so many dives for you I
don't care what you're going to do with
it Thank You Declan be prepared to leave
this house soon now I have two knives I
don't know what they are for but do
pa'dar Babu I will show them in eyes why
do I need to knows hey here dope
contracts I've got to work on something
different at the moment please come back
later
what about contracts knife me knife you
Knight knife us knife us telescope what
is that gonna do
that doesn't work I often can't find any
sleep at night
then I like to observe the stars through
my telescope
righty-ho then can I stay a bit oh here
we go oh boy ah right it's dead
oh sweet it's good that was good job me
I don't think I did it right not again
I'm so thirsty let's have dinner I know
what I need to do I know what I need to
do I know what I need to do I need to do
I know what I need to do I know I know I
know I know
here it is oh I know what I need to do
can you give me another one another one
please just another one please Thank You
Declan this in the umbrella stand put
that in there for later I concealed a
knife inside the umbrella stand
Oh Frick yeah Oh Tom stab now I know
what to do yeah I know what to do ya get
stabbed stabbed you oh oh sorry Jordan
mr. Jordan okay see ya all right goodbye
oh let's get out of here no doubt a CAD
abso Thursday day 10 the fateful tenth
day mr. Fowler mr Gilmore waiting for
you have a pleasant stay AB relased dad
this died for the umbrellas dead don't
buy B what happens if I step I don't
want to hurt him I'm sure I don't yeah
sure okay alright alright what I just
wanted to know don't blame me don't
judge me I just want to see what would
happen if you're dumb I don't want to
actually stab him ah stabbed dead
stabbed
well that was quick
pretty blatant murder right there
nothing much else to say about that
let's get out of here can we really
leave now mummy yes my dear
ah this creature won't detain us any
longer we'll leave this nightmare never
lie don't look at me like that oh my god
you managed to escape after 10 days
right I mean by all accounts it was a
pretty pleasant dinner it was not bad at
all
that was actually really cool but I
liked it
not bad not bad at all so anyway that
was dinner with an owl
did you enjoy it was it good it was a
little creepy like it was his it was
just unsettling like just enough creepy
to be unsettled which I kind of liked so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know where you thought down in
the comments below and as always I will
see you
[Music]